et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec renaud muselier président de
la région sud provence alpes côte d'azur
et de l'association des régions france
membre du conseil d'administration de
l'institut de militaires année
infections vous êtes aussi médecin
renaud muselier également de formation
et prochain il faut le préciser de
didier raoul tu pour apporter la
contradiction le docteur laurent
alexandre ancien chirurgien écrivains
notamment sur la thématique de
l'intelligence artificielle
vous n'êtes pas du tout convaincu 1 par
les analyses du professeur raoul qui
fait tant polémique bonsoir messieurs en
tout cas merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors avant de
lancer les débats je vous propose
justement d'écouter le professeur didier
raoult était sa nouvelle analyse de
l'épidémie dans une vidéo publiée hier
sur son compte twitter clairement il
n'est pas inquiet très loin de l'idée
d'un re confinement on voit que un peu
partout les choses sont en train de
s'arrêter
qu'il s'agisse des cas détectés
conditions de forme on a tous les cas
détectés et l'écart hospitalisé une et
capitaliser en réanimation est morte
assouan plus long parce que
malheureusement il restera quelques
morts qui sont actuellement en
réanimation qui vont apparaître
et on voit que cet épisode là est en
train de se résoudre et qu'il ya une
part de deuxième vague ou de d'autres
chameau c'est la cour banal il y aura
quelques cas sporadiques qui
apparaîtront ici ou là et entraînements
s'il ya quelqu'un qui est super
contagieux il y aura quelques cas autour
de lui mais tout ça ne traduit plus une
dynamique épidémique est mis en train de
se terminer
alors on aimerait évidemment le croire
le docteur house laurent alexandre
l'épidémie qui va disparaître alors ça
veut pas dire que le virus va
disparaître trop optimistes selon vous
ben je crois qu'il faut être très très
prudent
nous nous sommes tous trompés en janvier
et février moi personnellement je
pensais que l'épidémie ne dépasserait
pas dix mille morts
je me suis complètement trompé et au
même moment le professeur raoul expliqué
que l'épidémie ne toucherait pas
l'europe qu'elle ne concernerait que
quelques chinois et puis qu'elle serait
moins de victimes que les accidents de
trottinettes
nous sommes donc tous trompés donc
aujourd'hui nous devons avoir beaucoup
d'humilité
imaginez qu'on se trompe une deuxième
fois qu'on annonce qu'il n'y aura pas de
deuxième vague épidémique
les gens vont relâcher leur effort et on
risque d'avoir un confinement sévère
dans trois semaines un mois deux mois
déjà avec le premier confinement la
croissance le pouvoir d'achat va baisser
de 8% cette année en france et pareil
dans d'autres pays
en belgique chez moi en italie en
espagne
si on a un deuxième confinement cette
fois ci c'est pas eu % de baisse de la
production qu'on va avoir c'est 15 à 20
% et 15 à 20% l'économie de nos pays ne
peut pas le supporter donc je crois
qu'il faut être prudent
eq avant d'expliquer qu'il n'y aura pas
de deuxième pic
il faut en être certain il ne faut
surtout pas inciter les français par des
propos un peu léger à relâcher leur
vigilance car l'économie française ne
peut pas supporter un deuxième
confinement cette fois ci on aurait des
centaines de milliers de faillite et on
aurait une montée du chômage à 5 6 7
millions de personnes
comme on a connu après la crise de 1929
donc par pitié ne faisons pas croire aux
gens qu'il est certain qu'il n'y aura
pas de deuxième digue parce que cela va
les inciter à relâcher leur vigilance et
ce serait vraiment dramatiques en termes
de mortalité et puis aussi en terme de
conséquences économiques
renaud muselier les propos léger qui
peuvent avoir des conséquences
tous les propos d'un scientifique de ce
niveau ont toujours des conséquences
officer out ne s'est jamais inscrit dans
la polémique
il a publié semaine après semaine le
fruit de ses travaux au sein de son
institut dans les publications qui sont
confrontés à des publications mondiale
il ya trois semaines où quatre chemins
lundi comme d'habitude et publie le fait
que cette cloche qui monte vite dans le
cadre de piquet qui diminue au fil du
temps apporte des réponses pays par pays
en fonction du niveau de confinement et
du respect de ces normes sanitaires qui
ont été imposées à nos populations ne
fait que constater suivre nous avons
nous ici dans la région commencent à
côte d'azur et tout particulièrement à
marseille on m'a fait des tests sur
toulon et sionistes de façon à tester le
plus grand nombre de populations
possible en sorte que finalement ben on
teste on isole n'ayant ne confine pas en
famille dans le fond de kloster une
traite est ce que raconte pas raisonner
je soutiens depuis toujours mais
globalement quand même là plutôt raison
et on voit bien c'est qu'au bout du
petit sortir et attention le discours de
nos confrères
mais là où tu lui fais une analyse
froide et qui forcément peut poser
quelques difficultés mais après ça
dépasse en effet alors 300 et c'est là
où je rejoins parfaitement la nécessité
du résultat c'est que nous avons été
confinée pendant deux mois que les
français ont été très respectueux de ce
confinement et que si aujourd'hui cette
courbe s'inverse et c'est pas le fruit
de la magie c'est le fruit du travail
conséquent de nos concitoyens sacrifices
qu'ils ont fait ensemble confinement a
classé à casser la chaîne de
transmission et que 407e de transmission
nous avons dans les deux tiers de notre
pays aujourd'hui des lits hospitaliers
suffisamment nombreux pour faire en
sorte qu'on puisse soigner des cas
épidémiologique nouveau à côté de ça
dans le propos il ya le volet économique
ces deux choses différentes en route il
y peint qu'il faut sortir dans la rue
demain en ne mettant pas les masques en
ne mettant pas léger on ne respecte pas
sa tion ça c'est une obligation mais
c'est pas son propos il n'hésite pas
attention à ne pas respecter les gestes
barrières et donc il faut rajouter aux
propos de monsieur raout que l'épidémie
est en train doucement de partir mais
qu'il ne faut en aucun cas dans le cadre
des conclusions
l'art est engagé potentiellement par une
absence des gestes-barrières là ou plus
je suis parfaitement d'accord nous dans
la région provence alpes côte d'azur ces
5 millions d'euros sur le plan
économique nous avons perdu sur le
tourisme attendus tout à l'heure un
reportage au début des repêchages était
justement des feux de route feux avant à
la commission plein temps et j'ai mis en
place les projets européens sur le
tourisme mais c'est essentiel que l'on
puisse se dépasser son continent
européen n'est sûr que l'europe n'est
pas là pour fram et ajouter les
frontières mais par contre organiser les
déplacements dans les avions
est-ce que la lufthansa est ce que quand
m est-ce que air france va faire les
mêmes barrières sanitaires sur la
totalité de l'europe
c'est ça l'enjeu absolue non alors
messieurs je voulais aussi vous faire
réagir pendant des mois pour pour rester
dans le sujet du débat je voulais aussi
vous faire réagir sur un autre extraire
des vidéos du professeur raoul tu
extrait dans lequel il répond justement
à ses détracteurs un nombreux sur
l'hydro chloroquine son fameux
traitement ces essais les patients
soignés écouter ce qu'il en est on peut
pas dans une épidémie dit on ne soigne
pas les gens comme ça je pense que c'est
mis en place à quelque chose qui est
très étonnant c'est on ne soigne pas les
gens ensuite on a interdit aux gens de
prescrire des médicaments qui pourrait
marcher interdit aux médecins de le
faire ce qui n'empêche pas les gens qui
étaient les plus riches et les plus
fortunés de trouver comment soigner et
quand même c'est les plus pauvres qui
avait pas de raison qu'ils ont pas
réussi à voir les médicaments et donc
ces épidémies ne doivent pas faire de
perdre les nerfs
au point qu'on en oublie la médecine
elle même la médecine c'est s'occuper du
malade et soigné hospitalisés quand ils
vont pas bien
elles auront alexandre ça c'était une
critique qui est revenu jusque dans les
rangs de l'assemblée nationale 1
certains députés qui ont pris part à ce
groupe sur les réseaux sociaux laisser
les prescrire à ce que justement on ne
sait pas soigner
les gens france on a oublié la médecine
elle même par trop peut-être de
précaution non avant de donner à des
millions de personnes un traitement qui
n'a pas été évalué dans cette indication
il faut être prudent
je rappelle et ça ne va pas faire
plaisir à mon confrère le docteur
muselier que les études qu'on fait
didier raoul tu ou qu'on fait le
professeur personne qui est le grand
allié dans cette affaire du processeur à
ault sont pourris
ce sont des études qui sont
méthodologiquement pourri l'étude qui
vient de sortir et qui a été faite par
le professeur peron et qui a été
longuement à prouver sur les réseaux
sociaux par didier rahout est pourri
cette étude et méthodologiquement
scandaleuse l'ordre des médecins et l'
agence nationale de la sécurité du
médicament engueuler il ya quelques
jours mais manifestement pas
suffisamment quand on voit le professeur
peron dans cette étude soutenue
massivement sur les réseaux sociaux par
didier raoul tu sais permis de retirer
les malades graves les malades qui
mouraient les malades qui allait en
réanimation du groupe hydroxy
chloroquine pour les mettre dans l'autre
bras on se dit qu'il ya vraiment quelque
chose qui ne va plus il faut revenir à
la rigole sur l'évaluation des
médicaments
il ne faut plus que nous soyons là exe
des pays étrangers
quand vous voyez le portrait qui a été
fait de didier raoul tu dans le new york
times hier on a un petit peu honte
d'être français en tout cas moi j'ai un
peu honte d'être médecin français il
faut maintenant qu'on revienne aux
essais cliniques à la bonne pratique
médicale et qu'on évalue les médicaments
avec beaucoup de rigueur
on ne peut plus se permettre de faire
des essais pour i comme didier raoul tu
as fait et je je je m'insurge contre les
gens qui minimisent la mauvaise qualité
méthodologique des essais du professeur
à holt qui s'est permis des choses
absolument inqualifiable qui d'ailleurs
ont conduit je le répète l'ordre des
médecins et l' agence de sécurité du
médicament a haussé le ton il faut
maintenant revenir à la rigueur
pharmacologiques
car sur une maladie grave qui tue quand
même une personne sur 200 il faut qu'on
soit certain de ce que l'on dit quand on
évalue les médicaments il faut qu'on
soit certain de ce que donne d'hydroxyde
chloroquine on ne peut pas se permettre
de se baser sur les intuit
on dézingue des autres j'ai débattu
récemment avec le prof sur peron le
grand allié donc je le répète de didier
raoul tu il a quand même oser me dire ce
que la médecine ne se faisait pas à
partir de statistiques mais à partir de
ses tripes
non la médecine de 2020 ce n'est pas la
médecine de 1950 elle ne se fait pas à
partir des tripes et de l'intuition du
grand professeur elle se faire partir
des résultats à partir des chiffres il
faut que nous retrouvions la rigueur
pharmacologique c'est nécessaire parce
que la france est en train de devenir la
risée des experts internationaux en
d'évaluation du médicament
le mot de la fin renaud muselier la
réaction les propos un petit peu dur à
vos quêtes proche de didier rahout
devant je connais pas monsieur
professeur pérol à qui s'est donc nous
reprenons les régler sa vie dans ma
famille j'ai eu quatre membres touchés
ses huit membres de mon cabinet j'ai eu
29 membres de notre région
j'ai dépister très tôt j'ai fermé hôtel
de région est dépisté très tôt la
totalité du personnel tout seul tu
électoniques positifs ont été isolés et
traités soigner aucun en animation aucun
cas secondaire donc leur apporte une
réponse
deuxièmement on ne sait pas parler je
voulais parler il ne faisait pas coûté
de bruit mois donc moi je connais bien
le professeur out il et je passe je vous
ai parlé d'une méthode de l'egypte n'a
encore jamais gagné mais je voulais
laisser parler donc voilà messieurs le
professeur à août et de dimension
internationale
ne vous en déplaise les nobélisables
donc alors peut-être qu'il nous déplaît
dès que vous n'êtes pas d'accord mais si
vous vous en voyez d'autres estiment
qu'il est capable d'être prix nobel et
si ça fait envie d'autres peuvent être
très fiers de leurs professeurs en août
dans la médecine française
il a un institut hospitalo
universitaires qui est une ancienne
européenne qui reconnu dans le monde
entier et c'est une publication qui sont
près de 300 parents sont dans toutes les
évolutions scientifiques
mais peu importe là c'est un autre débat
dans le débat qui est aujourd'hui le
nôtre où ces raouts apporte une
prévenance crettenand globalement
maintenant on verra plus tard
après les faits qu'il y aura mais pour
un instant pour un médecin quand
quand vous soigner quelqu'un et que vous
y avez en face de vous on a donc une
capacité de le traiter de lui apporter
une solution médicale est bien avec ce
traitement de monsieur route
vous n'avez pas de casse n'est pas de
dégâts collatéraux n'ai pas de mots
n'est pas de réanimation vous avez en
tout cas une approche médicamenteuse
vis-à-vis du patient qui lui apporte une
solution
alors après on me dit c'est pas possible
c'est pas vrai qu'on verra exactement ce
qu'il en est nous nous sommes collés à
vitaly avait la région provence alpes
côte d'azur où la région italienne a été
considérablement touché
nous sommes des régions de france est
repassée le plus tard dans le rouge
une somme une région de france est
ressorti le plus tôt du rouge alors
est-ce que c'est l'effet maintenant on
verra de dire que pour autant dans cette
période d'urgence le système de travail
d'organisation de monsieur perrault ne
sais pas qui c'est mais de prouver ce
raout est pourri et complètement
aléatoire et amanda rues dépourvues de
bon sens scientifique mon cher collègue
merci à tous les deux laurent alexandre
renaud muselier d'avoir été avec nos de
débattre
ensemble donc ce soir merci à vous deux